[Music]
he also has a new edition of carpool
karaoke with singing superstar and
Sheeran say the chain singing we found
another doctor he's got some quite
tricky lyrics and so I really really
rehearsed in my car just on my own
people driving past me just thought I
was insane just for ages just doing that
em cuz that was the blazes or flames in
the third stage and a fire brigade
ladies I saw flames from the side of the
stage in the fire gate comes in a couple
of days and it just tryin to do that for
as long as I could so that I could make
love you
it's been called the carpool karaoke
that could break the internet James and
n who's the biggest male artist in the
world shot the skit last February but
it's been in the works way longer I've
been in touch with James Corden about
this for three years because he wants me
to see the first one and I just wasn't
wasn't around - a buggy karaoke with
that isn't the only thing we can't wait
to see as Corden broadcast The Late Late
Show from London next week
he was just caught filming a new
crosswalk the musical James dressed as
Mary Poppins sings a spoonful of sugar
and let's go fly a kite with Sir Ben
Kingsley warning my accent gets thicker
when I'm back home even I don't know
what I'm saying
who needs to understand what James is
saying just watching is fun enough
[Music]
you